all right so this is a tour a talk that
was actually a talk by commission that a
few weeks ago I received an email from
der eat asking me very specifically to
speak about the embezzler of
entanglement and monogamy and sort of
listing some things that she was
interested in and so I was very happy to
do that and in particular well I guess
what we're gonna be discussing today is
some kind of entanglement near quantum
mechanical analog of this little common
trick that you see right there that we
have six plain figures and we can just
slide them around and if we slide them
around appropriately we seem to have
created area out of nothing and we're
gonna see ways that it looks like we can
create entanglement out of nothing of
course we can't now that would be a
violation of the laws that I'm getting
getting to but the fact that we can come
close to doing it seems to have some
interesting applications so the
structure of the talk is first you know
the first law that we're gonna be
discussing is the fact that entanglement
cannot be created without interaction
and you know the evasion strategy is
going to be embezzlement and then there
going to be a number of applications and
this is going to be most if not all of
the talk in the end because DeRita asked
me to also speak about monogamy and so I
have a little bit to say about monogamy
but there's been so much good material
about monogamy over the course of the
past few days that you probably don't
need to hear too much more so if I
managed to make it this far
all I'm going to tell you about is a
very very simple manifestation of
monogamy my original ambition was to try
to take you through the proof of
Fernando and Aram's limitations on
Quantum's PCP but squeezing in both the
the embezzlement and that turned out to
be overly ambitious so that won't appear
thanks for an endo I managed to learn
how it worked but I won't be able to
share it with you alright so the great
laws part one this is something I think
is familiar familiar to all of you if
you have some density operator Rho a B
for a composite quantum system on a part
and B part and then you have some noisy
operation that acts in a product product
fashion on the into B parts so again for
those of you who are not familiar with
this I think there may be a few of you
in the audience the quantum mechanical
analog of a dub of a stochastic
Mapp is a completely positive tres
preserving that you can formalize all
those things and what you and you have a
data processing inequality that if you
look at the mutual information before
you started which is simply defined as
in the obvious way the entropy of Roe
restricted to a plus the entropy of Rho
restricted to B minus the joint entropy
of Rho a B that that cannot increase
under these product operations right so
you can't create correlation from
nothing now what is embezzlement
well embezzlement roughly speaking is
theft from a reservoir of wealth so vast
that no one notices that you've
committed a crime right that's a in the
ideal world and this is the malla
propylene named Bernie Madoff who made
off with hundreds of millions of dollars
of his own of his clients money and of
course no one notices until they do
that's a more current photo all right so
what are we going to do with when we
embezzle entanglement our perfect crime
is going to be that we start off with
some entanglement reservoir right so
this is this quantum state Phi and
imagine this is going to be a large
store of entanglement and then we also
start off with some system in a product
state you know Alice has a zero and Bob
has a zero and we're gonna want to
convert that by unitary operations to
again vast store of entanglement in some
target states sigh so just more
pictorially again here's our
entanglement bank we start off with a
product state in our target register we
act unitarily you know Alice does
something on her side Bob does something
on his side and what we'd like to get
out is a new state where we have again
the original entanglement bank Phi and
the target states I which to be
non-trivial is not a product state with
some kind of entangled State so this
would be perfect embezzlement but this
is also obviously impossible because it
violates the the first great law that I
showed you on the previous slide that if
we look at the original mutual
information will have the mutual
information for the state Phi plus the
mutual information of a product state
which is zero and then afterwards we'd
have the mutual information for the
state Phi plus the mutual information
for the state's side
so state is a court so if sy is a
correlated state or an entangled state
of any type we will have increased the
mutual information by acting locally
which is impossible so this cannot this
cannot be done right this is this is
fault yeah this is well impossible I
guess I should have said that right well
actually there's there is a sense in
which it can be done right there's a
trivial solution to this problem which
is just to have an infinite reservoir
from entanglement not a very very large
reservoir but infinite and if you steal
you know a dollar from an in know from a
banquet then if it amount of money the
bank still hasn't phenomenal money and
you can unfortunately I wasn't at the
discussion yesterday because I was
preparing this talk but I think there
was there was some discussion of the
extent to which this is actually sort of
a valid statement and from the
mathematical perspective at least you
can formalize this and you can really
make it a rigorously you know valid
statement the physical route relevance
is less clear right like whether you
were because in practice you never have
access to an infinite number of degrees
of freedom that you can control
effectively and so if we if we want to
think about the physical relevance of
entanglement we probably should be
thinking about finite finite dimensional
models but not entirely don't marry us
might have an objection so let's yeah
oh yeah sure so yeah the data processing
hooked an equality is satisfied yeah
yeah that's the loophole in this case
that you can't you know mathematically
you can't have this perfect in-tank
perfect embezzlement whether you could
ever achieve it physically is less clear
um so let's actually proceed to make it
clear at least but this this effect is
potentially physically relevant well I
guess here are the drawbacks right you
know the Federal Reserve does not have
an infinite amount of entanglement but
there's actually another draw drawback
with this scheme oh because I haven't
told you exactly what I want to achieve
yet but at least this form of
embezzlement where we have an infinite
number of copies of sigh only works if
we want to embezzle sighs right
and I would like to be more ambitious
now I would like to actually construct a
scheme where there's a single embezzling
state from which I can embezzle anything
I want any part take you know any any
bipartite quantum state as long as it's
not too big and that's what we're going
to try to achieve and how do we achieve
it well one way to do it is to use these
embezzling States so this is the class
of bipartite quantum states that wind
band and I introduced from 2002 and the
structure of them is just that the
Schmidt coefficient so it said you know
Alice and Bob are using the same the
same basis sort on orthonormal basis and
the coefficients at front are 1 over
square root of J so if you want to think
in terms of the eigenvalues of the
reduced density operator the eigenvalues
are proportional to the harmonic
sequence 1 over J and so the
normalization constant here is roughly
CN is roughly log N and now the ambition
of course the data processing inequality
does apply because as the finite
dimensional state and so we cannot
embezzle perfectly and all we're going
to be able to achieve now is some
approximation all right and the little
theorem that we proved is that for every
pure States I on a prime B prime
whatever it is
of Schmidt ranked em again that's just
jargon for those of you who aren't used
to that but the Schmidt rank is just the
the rank of the reduced density operator
so very coarse measure of how much
entanglement is there there exist
unitary transformations on the Alice
Tyne and the Bob side that will convert
one of these embezzling states in a
product state into the embezzling state
at a target and the inner product is
going to be at least one minus the log
of the Schmidt rank of the target over
the Schmidt rank of the embezzling state
so if you want to get a little bit you
insult maybe a little bit easier to see
if you want this inner product to be one
minus Epsilon
then you have to blow up the number of
qubits you're embezzling state has to be
one over epsilon times the size of your
target state it's not too bad that's a
that's a polynomial blow-up yeah so it's
not it's not outrageously large it's not
infinite and and so that's the statement
now I should say that when women I came
up with this we just thought it was a it
was a curiosity oh yeah it was kind of
cool that you could do this but at the
time I guess the quantum information
world was very focused on state
transformations and the amount of
entanglement required to get him to
convert from one state to another and
there was a you know there's a lot of
excitement about the idea of catalysis
right this kind of looks like you tell
us that we started with this state Phi
and 0 0 and we catalytically transform
it to Phi and something else but you
damage the catalyst in the process here
so it's not really you know because of
this one minus epsilon and so we're not
really operating catalytically we're
sort of damaging the catalysts as we go
and so we thought it was a you know as a
cheat it was neat but because oh the
only thing that ever mattered in the
world obviously was how much entangle
that you consumed no one ever would ever
use this for anything and in fact we
even had some difficulty publishing it
for precisely that reason that the the
the referees were sort of steeped in the
same prejudices as us and that's kind of
how it stood for several years no one
used it for anything and it's kind of
been gratifying that in the past few
it's found a number of applications in
quantum complexity but before getting to
those applications let's just see how it
works
so let us show you how to embezzle a
bell pair the easiest case things get a
little bit more confidential
combinatorially complicated for other
types of states but you get the picture
if you're good if you look at this one
so let's just look at the Schmidt
coefficients so the state Phi n are
embezzling state here are the Schmidt
coefficients the normalization and then
B the square root of the harmonic
sequence and then if we look at the
embezzling state and our target 10 surd
with our target here's the whole
collection of Schmidt coefficients right
each one from the original is doubled
and multiplied by 1 over square root 2
now if we wanted to convert the
embezzling state tenths are 0 0 so
they're bunch of trailing zeros here
that I've left out in 2 Phi n tensor
sign what should we do well we should
just actually align the Schmidt
coefficients or try to transform
transform the Schmidt coefficients of
Phi n into the short coefficients of Phi
n tensor sign right that's what we
should that's what we should try to do
right because we can we can per me buy
it locally acting on a and B we can
permute the Schmidt basis right so we
have the freedom to reorder these
Schmidt coefficients and so if we can
just find a way to reorder the Schmidt
coefficients such that the the dot
product between them is large and tells
us that we can actually embezzle so the
obvious way to reorder the Shred
coefficients is just you know order them
largest to smallest right so we just
order them largest to smallest and look
at the inner product and what do we get
well we'll pick up a 1 over square root
of CN squared so there's 1 over C n
which is 1 over log n right the harmonic
the harmonic sum that we're using to
normalize and then we'll have the inner
product of 1 over square root of 1 times
1 over square root of 2 which is at
least 1/2 and we actually have a half
and then 1 over square root of 3 times 1
over square root of 4 gives at least 1
over 4 and then an actual 4 and so on
right so that's what the inner product
looks like
but this inner product is actually
1/2 plus 1/2 which is 1 plus 1/4 plus
1/4 or sorry a quarter plus 1/4 which is
1/2 so this it that all the way up to 2
1 over n plus 1 over N which is 2 over n
so that we've now bounded this inner
product by another harmonic sum right
and so this thing in the parentheses is
roughly the harmonic sum from 1 over 1
to 2 over n so it's roughly the log of n
over 2 and so we have a lower bound on
the inner product of log of n over 2
over log n which is about 1 minus the
log of T over log N and of course log of
2 here is the Schmidt rank of our target
State
all right that's exactly the role that
it's playing and it turns out that the
hardest yeah the the state that is
hardest to embezzle physically is the
maximally entangled state like this it's
actually the easiest state to embezzle
mathematically right if I want to
illustrate you how it works that if we
had other kinds of Schmidt coefficients
the problem is that when you reorder
things the way that your reorder
coefficients becomes more complicated
but it turns out that the lower bound
the worst lower bound you get for these
maximally entangled states so that's how
you that's how you embezzle with these
these states that we we found way back
when so since then there has been some
further development yes you know instead
of just lining up coefficients if you
were to describe what the procedure
would be is that easy to describe oh
sure so let's see we
we have found a permutation that takes
the Schmidt coefficients of Phi n almost
rather so Phi n was already in this
order and then we found a permutation on
the Smit coefficients of Phi n tensor
psy that aligns them very well with the
Schmidt coefficients of Phi n right so
we what we do is we apply the inverse of
that permutation J were to be written in
binary let's say then you're just like
yanking out the most or the least
significant bit oh maybe that's actually
another way of thinking about it okay
maybe for the login belt that's enough
proof depending on this car this state
oh yeah yeah I mean actually I don't
know the the only lower bound we
bothered to prove was this Wagga Schmidt
shrank over log n so I don't know the
extent I mean you should be able to do a
little bit better with other states but
we haven't analyzed how much better you
can do yeah well assuming that the so
they are essentially permutation
matrices like you have to write psy in
its basis as well and then once you've
done that it's a permutation matrices
yeah no Alice and Bob both have to do it
because they have to move this they have
to move it yeah so they agree on on the
Schmidt decomposition
and is it always that you reorder them
increasingly in the sentence state so
that's that's how you maximize one of
the projects that yeah so now that will
always be a big question um and I'll get
to that a little bit on the next slide
oh okay so some further developments
again not much happened for quite a
while but then there's this paper by
Debbie Ben toner and John Waters
nominally from 2013 which is when it was
published but if you look on the archive
that appeared in 2008 and they did a
number of interesting things in that
paper but the one that I'd like to focus
on just for the moment is that they also
showed that you can embezzle multi-party
States not just bipartite states but the
strategy is extremely inefficient so the
blow up rather than being polynomial is
doubly exponential in the size of the
state and so it can be done in principle
but you might object to it not being
very practical um so another interesting
development just this year is that Eric
Turner Thomas and store rental members
personally came up the robust
embezzlement protocol so in the stranded
in the problem that I just described to
you Alice and Bob both agree on the
target state side right but you can
imagine a situation where Alice and Bob
are you know don't quite agree on what
state they're trying to make and because
that can affect the ordering of the
schmitt coefficients that could in
principle lead to some problem but what
they've shown is that even if Allison
Bob don't quite agree on the target sir
there's a robust version of the
investment procedure that Willa will
succeed and they call this quantum
correlated sampling I'm not talking
about applications here except for this
one because I'm not going to explain
anything more about it but it turns out
that proving this quantum correlated
sampling lemma is a key step in their
proof of parallel repetition for
projection games also I guess in 2003
Debbie and
a student looked at characteristics of
these Universal embezzling van of
families right as this state that I
wrote down for you the only one is there
more that you can do and they showed
that you can perturb the coefficients a
little bit but there's not there's not a
lot of room but it but doing so didn't
seem to buy them very much that if your
goal was to do a universal universal
embezzlement that didn't seem to improve
on the fidelity and so that's that's
what it is um and coming out this year
so I've received some advance notice
although no paper people could in the
mathematical physics and operator
algebra community well and also are
alright quantum information Reinhardt
murder
Volker Schultz all writing a paper they
called the universal embezzling algebra
and they show some you know they're
gonna prove in that paper some type of
uniqueness for a writing then quotes
eigenvalue scaling in the limit of
infinite dimensions where you can do
perfect perfect embezzlement Oh
so there's a whole form on the other
there's a mathematical formulas that one
can use to talk about it and they're
going to do that and one of the
consequences which was known sort of in
some sense earlier but this you may find
this interesting that if you have a free
quantum field theory so an unattractive
quantum field theory I turns out that
every valid state in the theories in
embezzling state all right so it's not
just that these embezzling states are
kind of rare things in fact if you just
take any pure state of the system and
then chop chop it in half you know they
can a a to be what you have there's
embezzling sorry what's the faithful I
mean ok oh yes so it was a tables once
you look at these yeah ok so this all
seems to be very you know very recent
developments modulo you know the late
submission to the journal but I think
we'd be remiss in not acknowledging in
fact that there's much you know there
are much much earlier developments in
this business of embezzling and going
all the way back really to the late
1960s when people were thinking about
it's the classification of Unknowing
algebras you know they weren't using the
language of embezzlement yeah we're much
better at marketing in the quantum
information community but I believe it
was a rocky who noticed that for certain
types of on ointment algebras you can
have some effect that was essentially
embezzling and this is a kind of
invariant that separated those algebras
from others and so this was some step in
the classification of a dimensional bond
in algebra sorry
okay so so the story is an old one yeah
oh sure yeah
Oh interesting okay yeah it's like in
the same sense that if like if you have
an optical coherence state you lose some
photons it remains a coherence so where
the harmonic but well factorial is a lot
different no no I think that the N in
the coherent state the number of photons
corresponds to the number of EPR pairs
so I mention the superposition of EPR
pairs that someone distributed then we
move one you get approximately back the
same space right that's the connection
okay good so so so the effect is the
notice the video and other avenues
before yeah like if you a finite
dimensional hilbert space new state at
random oh no I don't think so
it's too entangled oh so they get random
states in the hilbert space are almost
maximally entangled and it turns out
that maximally entangled states are not
there they're good for embezzling
maximally entangled states but they're
not good for embezzling these other
types of states because you somehow need
enough Aaron would use the word spread
in the initial eight coefficients to be
able to reproduce any distribution that
you're trying to make so it has to look
like the oneness - yeah like that I mean
essentially that specifically there is
this you know in some asymptotic limit
that's kind of uniqueness result but it
essentially this is the only possibility
yeah it doesn't have to be case
regularly
I mean I think it just has to be K and
not too fast not too slow
so that's possible and having not seen
you know their their paper I'm not sure
but Volker did say to me that it really
had to look like yeah look like one over
the I guess what's it called this the
spectral scale has to look like one over
one over T and you know in some limit
your protocol does not need
communication between the parties but
not even classical no okay is it
come on do better if from your most
classical communication um well if you
allow classical communication then you
can embezzle with EPR yeah with a large
you know an infinite store BPR pairs
allows you to embezzle anything because
once you have EPR pairs you can just
convert ya degrade them to loot them
into other types of entanglement so in
that sense you can do better in terms of
the fidelity I think you might be able
to do somewhat better sorry
oh so you do it exactly what but you
still have to you still to embezzle the
original state to do the teleportation
right like you need you if you want so
if you had an infinite number of EPR
pairs your vessel one and then you can
teleport you've done everything
perfectly but if you just have a finite
embezzling state you the state you're
gonna teleport through will not be a
perfect fidelity but that does give a
strategy so I mean I haven't analyzed
this is true I mean it for a fifth
number it's the same but yeah so the
only well they're they're actually so
there are other strategies like ya know
you can do better you can do better
because in their paper
Debbie Lee Jung toner and walkers they
came up with another thing
of embezzling states that are targeted
for nestling a specific state right so
these I've been talking about Universal
embezzling states here but if you want
if you want to embezzle just some
specific state then you can use theirs
and you'll get a better scaling of the
fidelity and then you tell yes I think
you can't do better at least better than
the known strategy other questions
oh it doesn't matter okay so let's
actually see what we would use this for
there been a lot of really beautiful
depictions of two-player and we'll hear
ya games so I'm gonna compete here for
the ugliest picture that you play our
game but here we have Alice and Bob
Alice on the Left Bob on the right Alice
gets a question Amy Bob gets a question
B and Alice performs a measurement
indexed by the question likewise
rhuebottom's and their outcomes j and k
and they share some quantum state and
the quantum value of the game is the
supreme 'm over the dimension of the
Hilbert space in which Rho lives to
mention over the measure of our supreme
over the measurements supreme over the
state of the average over the
distribution of questions the payoff
function and then the probability of the
same formula we've been seeing many
times
so one trivial football and I shouldn't
say trivial but this was observed in
2010 there's just a premium over the
state here but we can we can remove the
supreme over the state and just always
use the same embezzling state right
because we know then the limit of large
dimension that will allow us to recover
any possible measurement statistics that
we want with arbitrarily high fidelity
right so at least in this sense the
investi of you these embezzling states
give you a fixed family of states that
you can use when you're trying to
analyze multiplayer games oh I don't
know that anyone's actually use this for
anything but in principle it works um
and I guess here's an open question what
I want I alluded to this earlier so that
in the two-player case we know that
these embezzling states are only
polynomially larger than the original
target state but in the multi-party
setting in principle you can do the same
thing but you incur this terrible
terrible blow up in the size of the
entangled state you're talking about
so finding more efficient multi party
embezzling states and they could be a
very interesting problem or showing that
they don't exist so a more interesting
example and this also comes from
Debbie's paper with John is is used to
make a point about about wealth in this
case two-player games in particular
showing that you cannot get by with any
finite amount even Jekyll
at least in some games and so they look
at two-player cooperative what they call
quantum games so it's like
generalization of the model that most
people have been talking about in this
meeting where the messages between Alice
and the referee are quantum you are
allowed to be quantum mechanical not
just classical messages so the referee
produces some quantum state row which
has three parts an S part in our part
than T part because s mt to alice and
bob respectively
Alice and Bob can also share some
entangled state to help them along in
the same way that people have been
talking about all week so Alice performs
some physical transformation on her s
register and Phi and then sends back an
aid but it is now quantum data and
likewise for Bob and then the referee
performs a projection and if you that if
or a measurement and if it gets a
particular outcome he declare success
okay so let's try a particular example
of this game so the initial state that's
going to be prepared by the referee is
this one here
so it's an equal superposition of two
possibilities when the referee is 0 the
state on SMT is a product 0 0 and when
the referee has one the state on SMT is
going to be an entangled state now the
vehicle the state is going to be
orthogonal to 0 0 so it's in a different
sector of the Hilbert space and it's
actually integrable now the objective is
that Alice and Bob are going to try to
make a GF sensing starting from this
right and then the projection is going
to be the projection onto this G of said
state and so if Alice and Bob managed to
make the gh dead state they win and if
they fail or they're going to lose with
some some positive probability so what
can we observe about this well if Alice
and Bob can apply arbitrary unit ares to
their joint quantum system then this is
easy right because there's a unitary
transformation that takes 0 0 to 0 0 and
takes the superposition of 1 1 & 2 2 to
1 1 right that's a unitary transient
thats a unitary transformation so if
Allison bog were completely
unconstrained and Kodak could act
collectively then they could succeed
they can make the g-h said state but of
course they are physically separated so
they can only apply product operations
right and if you look at you know then
their options look much more limited
right because they what cuz they do well
Alice could say alright well in some
extra register or Alice and Bob
Alice could make a one and Bob can make
a one and they can swap out this state
and replace it with the one one state
right but if they were to do that
they would leave this entangled state in
the environment right like it would be
sitting there and it would decohere this
GH said right that the state would look
like zero zero zero and a one one one
but then out of the environment there
also be in the case of the zero zero
there'd be some product state and in the
case of the one one there'd be this
state here and so the be something
product versus something maximally
entangled and so there'd be
distinguishability in the environment
and you would not make the equal
superposition you could make some kind
of some kind of mixture all right and so
it's hard for them to do this if they if
they're physically separated so how you
know how do they succeed at this task
now well we remembered that they're
allowed to have an entangled state to
help them and the right entangled state
to choose is a really good embezzling
state
okay so Phi e DZ is a some really high
quality of Universal embezzling state
and then we observe that there's a local
unitary transformation on SMT that will
embezzle this target states I or from
the embezzling state right and so the
inverse of that transformation will take
the target and replace it with a product
state right and so by using embezzlement
they can actually but rather than
embezzling they're gonna run a vessel
right instead of you know taking
stealing money from the bank they're
gonna run to the bank with a pile of
cash and try to hide it and give it away
so that no one notices right and they
can use embezzlement
do precisely that oh sorry so the the
actual operation that is performed is a
conditional operation so Allison Bob
because the one more two sectors
orthogonal they know yeah so they
applied the identity on this sector and
then the embezzling operation that's so
the winning probability approaches one
as the dimension of the embezzling state
goes to infinity which is great right
that's interesting but in their paper
they can also prove again sort of
formalizing the intuition that I have
been giving you that that the success
probability is bounded away from one for
all finite dimensional and for all
finite dimensional entangled States fine
whether they did Universal embezzling
state or anything else right and so this
is an example of a two-player game in
which we know even though that you
specify the game it's very simple and
there you know it's only it requires
only a pair you know a two by three by
three dimensional system the amounts of
entanglement required to play it optimal
and optimally as unbounded okay so I I
wanted to point out actually that the
idea behind that protocol in the in this
game actually came up earlier and was
the very first application in quantum
quantum information at least of this
embezzling idea and it was used in the
proof of what's called the quantum
reversion theorem and I think it was
Aaron who first told me this and I was
ready to give him a hug right because
that was the first time anyone had ever
even proposed that this embezzlement
idea could be useful for anything so
what is this reverse Shannon theorem so
I think you know most of the people in
the audience you're familiar with
information theory if you have a channel
you allow yourself to use the channel
many times you can associate a capacity
right the maximum rate of which you can
say some bits noise the stick through
the channel using error correcting codes
and in the quantum setting you could do
the same thing with quantum mechanical
channels and while the classical
settings they shared redness between the
sender and the receiver doesn't improve
the capacity
and the quantum setting entanglement
between the sender and the receiver does
improve the capacity it actually makes
the whole thing easier to analyze but
then you could ask a further question
right ok so we can calculate these in
technical assistant capacities of
channels once we allow ourselves free
entanglement how many different kinds of
channels are there right like that's
yeah the the capacity is just one
parameter out of you know a whole bunch
you know that a whole big matrix that
that defines the channel and the theorem
is that in the presence of this
disentanglement
any channel can simulate any other
channel at a cost which is just given by
the ratio of their capacities all right
so that the more of the story is that as
when you are in the quantum setting when
you allow yourself free entanglement
between the sender and the receiver
there's only one parameter required to
define you know to characterize a
channel so it's a nice it's a beautiful
theorem in information theory and this
is a sort of bird's eye view of the
extremely complicated protocol that they
I'm not even gonna begin to tell you how
it works it doesn't matter um but they
the first draft of this paper I saw in
2001 and this is actually not just the
publication date but the date that I
went on the archive so it took them a
long time to get it to work partly
because it was so complicated but you'll
see that there's this kind of stuff
routine in here where they have
embezzling states you know and the issue
is that they have a number of different
brain you have different protocols that
they're going to try to perform in a
controlled unitary way but the different
protocols consume different amounts of
entanglement right and they want to do
it completely coherent lis and so if
there's any record of how much
entanglement was consumed that would
decohere the protocol just like in the
the game that I showed you in the
previous slide and so their strategy is
to take any unused entanglement and an
unindicted them to do everything
coherent lis and so this was the first
the first application of embezzlement I
think in quantum real application so ok
so again there's been a lot of really
yeah good material yeah beautiful talks
about monogamy so I don't know that I
have that much more to to tell you but
for those of you who don't you know more
a bit less familiar with quantum
information theory I thought I'd show
you one of the most trivial versions of
of monogamy um so the you know again and
another one of the great laws analogous
to the I guess the first law of
information or whatever was that showing
you earlier is that you cannot create
entanglement without not just
interaction but quantum mechanical
interaction
all right so entanglement is we have we
don't know exactly what it is but we do
know that it's something that you can't
make you know I can't make entanglement
with to read by just getting on the
phone and calling her in Jerusalem right
we have to have some kind of quantum
mechanical interaction and you can
formalize that in a way that doesn't
really the details don't matter then you
can come with the class local operations
in classical communication and if you're
going to try to measure entanglement
whatever it is it's something that
should not increase under these local
operations in classical communication
okay so another yeah the other great law
the monogamy law so every person human
physical or cryptographic Alice Allyson
Boggs whether they're actually qubits or
people doesn't matter shall be maximally
entangled with at most one other person
and that's you know the monogamy
statement the more entangled Alice's
involved the less entangled she can be
with Charlie so we've been using that
kind of language all week but it would
be nice to actually be able to have some
quantity that really Illustrated this
trade-off explicitly so I'm just gonna
give you an example and that you can
just give you confidence that when you
try to actually use this reasoning
you're not you know sort of going yeah
you're not walking on clouds or
something right there's something
concrete that can be made made truth
assistance I don't have too much time
volume so that Fernando I'll already
yell at them explained this a very
nicely but I'll do it again because
again for people who don't do one
information in theory this is the key
point um that if the quantum state is
cure all right
then the only states that you can extend
it with are going to be in tensor
product form with that state all right
so that's the monogamy statement and
it's just a static version of the note
a theorem that monogamy and no cloning
are essentially the same thing so if you
had a cloning machine you could violate
monogamy right and the way is very
simple we would take an entangled state
run one half of it through a cloner and
then both efforts of the cloner would be
entangled with a right um but likewise
if we can if we had polygamy we could we
could actually clone because if we could
somehow make him a state that was
maximally entangled between a say a
qubit a and both b1 and b2 right then we
could initiate teleportation and
teleport 5 into both copies of B right
and so manag you're trying to get a
sense of what monogamy means I mean it's
a property just linear algebra but it
really is the same thing as the new
cloning there now to make the things
quantitative I alluded to these
entanglement measures earlier so we
normally try to normalize entanglement
measures so that the the entanglement of
a pure state is just the entropy of its
reduced density operator because that's
that's a measure of how correlated they
are mutual information is twice this
quantity and there are no there are tons
of entangled measures that have been
studied over the years one is called the
entanglement cost and that's just the
minimal rate of bail pairs required to
make copies of your target state Rho AV
using only local operations in classical
communication all right so that's that
is the entanglement in the state in the
sense of how hard is it to make the
state using only loc see how much
entanglement resource do we need to
start with and so if we wanted to prove
something about monogamy this would be a
good place to start right we say okay
let's look at this entanglement cost
function so we could ask the question
for example is the entanglement cost of
a with B plus the entanglement cost of a
with C upper bounded by something useful
like the entropy right so the enriched
would be the entanglement of a with the
entire rest of the world and so morally
this should be true right we're always
talking about how tangled is just
monogamous but turns out it's not true
at all then a random cure
State on a large system ABC whose
dimensions are all the same have
entanglement costs with between a and B
and a and C that are both almost maximum
right so you can't just naively you know
say that any entanglement measure that
you pick up is going to be monogamous
it's not necessarily true um the sort of
at the opposite end of the spectrum of
the entanglement cost is the entangle
and of distillation so that is how
useful a quantum state is right so if I
have many copies of some railway B and I
want to only use local operations in
classical communications to extract Bell
pairs at what rate can I extract Bell
pairs and it turns out that some variant
of this does obey monogamy with the
entanglement cost so that the sum of the
entanglement cost and the attainment of
distillation is bounded above by the
entangled of a with the rest of the
world but there's a caveat which is that
I have a little arrow on there and what
that means is I'm not I'm not allowing
all possible LOC C operations only LOC C
operations in which Alice can send
messages to Bob but not the reverse and
it turns out this quantity isn't even
monotonic under the general loc C so
we've still failed to find an example of
a function which sort of captures our
intuition about entanglement in the
mixed state case um so here's a table
that just drawn from one of Fernando's
papers a few years ago and it lists a
whole pile of entanglement measures and
a whole pile of desirable properties but
you'll notice monogamy in the bottom row
there's something that is yes for the no
and no and no no then that monogamy is
actually kind of a difficult property of
fine for an entanglement measure but
there is one that satisfies it so I'll
just tell you very briefly what is this
functions that you can yeah you can be
confident that there is at least one way
of measuring entanglement that is
properly monogamous and by monogamous I
mean precisely this thing here this
quantities they call it squashed
entanglement of a with a whole bunch of
different bees is it most or rather the
sum of those in this one container is
that most the squashed entangled of a
with all the bees together and this
one's on its side is less than or equal
to the squashed entangled of a with the
whole rest of the world which is
the entropy to the inequality I was
showing earlier and of course that's
bounded above by the dimension okay so
um what should I tell you about it maybe
just the definition so we've seen before
this what does it mean to be entangled
it means that you cannot be written as a
convex combination of product States
right but if we have a separable state
that is a none entangled State we could
always extend it in this way right here
all right so we just look to our convex
combination it has an index J so we just
remember which term in the convex
decomposition we have on an extra
register and that new state for that new
state a and B are conditionally
independent yes yeah so I should say if
there exists a way of decomposing Rho AV
as a as a convex some of this form then
I just
I'm listening one particularly pages in
the oh yeah sure
yeah so it's not a function I'm just
saying suppose you can do this yeah so
if you can do this then the conditional
mutual information function will be 0
right because once I know J the state on
a and B is a product state right so the
mutual information on a and B once I
know C is 0 right and the definition of
this squashed entanglement is precisely
to commune to formalize this idea that
given a state row on a and B we think of
all possible ways of extending throw a V
to larger systems right so we have no
bound on the dimension of C we just
allow any possible extension and we look
at the infimum over all extensions of
this conditional mutual information and
one can prove it's 0 if and only if the
state is separable and it has that great
list of of desirable properties and I'll
leave it as an exercise for you for you
it's trivial to prove monogamy for this
function here and I'm out of time so
I'll just skip that and say here you
know here's the you know one lesson for
me if your result looks like a sneaky
but useless trick just wait for 10 years
you might be surprised
people find you know how people find
uses for I haven't spoken at all about
the applications of monogamy of
entanglement but I don't think you need
to be convinced of these applications
right right from the start of qkd you
know we can we can just choose talks at
random in this workshop and I think
roughly you know at least one third to a
half of them are using monogamy in some
fundamental way so thanks for your
attention
oh sure oh I mean that's I don't have
anything very deep to just say there but
it's just some kind of some intuition
that perhaps the the rigidity theorem
bhoomesh and then is is expressing the
fact you know not not just that the
state you know when you're looking at
the CHS that you gave that the state
you're looking at is something
particular state that can't be probably
the rest of the world but it's telling
you that the entire hilbert space and
the operations that you're working with
are decomposing in some tensor product
fashion so it feels to me like it's
similar in spirit to monogamy but you
know it's something much much stronger
there's no more questions maybe we'll go
to watching thank Patrick yeah